gauthier qu'y at il dans la tête de
vladimir poutine c'est la question que
tout le monde se pose déjà depuis depuis
un mois maintenant il est capable de
tout on vient d'entendre cet ancien
agent du kgb à les anciens renseignement
russes qui dit cette phrase effroyable
personne pour arrêter cas quel est le
plan qu'il peut avoir dessiné pour pur
pour l'europe de l'est alors d'abord
pour répondre à votre question
souvenez vous il ya encore même deux
semaines ou trois semaines la plupart
des diplomates occidentaux considérer
que la lumière poutine était un être
rationnel et que donc on pouvait avoir
accès à lui en négociant en lui
accordant certaines choses en refusant
certaines choses mais bref qu'il y avait
un moyen d'accéder à ce personnage ce
qu'on découvre aujourd'hui mais ce que
beaucoup de russes ont découvert depuis
très longtemps depuis 2003 2004 c'est
qu'il y a une dimension irrationnelle
entre guillemets c'est pas tout à fait
le bon mot c'est une dimension
idéologique ou vidéo logis prend le pas
sur les intérêts économiques sociaux
politiques même géopolitique c'est à
dire que aujourd'hui on ne peut pas
savoir à 100% ce que vladimir poutine a
dans la tête en ce sens que par exemple
récupérer l'ukraine oui pourquoi pas
mais après c'est très lourd d'occuper un
pays s'il entend vraiment l'annexé il
faut occuper un pays qui fait une fois
un peu plus de la dimension de la taille
de la france avec 44 millions
d'habitants éventuellement des
résistants la guérilla c'est très
compliqué est ce qu'il a pensé à cela
est ce que pour lui il passe au dessus
ou est ce qu'il admet la chose vous
voyez que c'est compliqué et surtout ce
qui surprend c'est que cette dimension
idéologique dont je parle elle n'a
quasiment jamais été prise en compte par
l'occident c'est pour ça que nous sommes
surpris aujourd'hui on croyait lettres
rationnel il ne l'est pas et dont c'est
à dire que lorsqu'ils reçoivent emmanuel
macron sur cette grande table au kremlin
et leurs deux jours plus tard olaf
scholz il sait déjà qu'il va très
probablement ont fait en tout cas c'est
dans les plans c'est à dire que si vous
voulez on ne mobilise pas entre 150
mille cent soixante dix mille hommes
depuis
l'automne depuis l'automne dernier pour
rien ou alors c'est qu'on fait des
manoeuvres en tout cas pour intimider
mais il ya quelque chose sinon vous
savez les manoeuvres c'est pas aussi
grand ça peut être vingt mille trente
mille hommes et la 150 milles en plus
avec l'artillerie c'est une armée
d'artilleurs l'armée russe donc il y
avait cette intention dans un point
peut-être assurances et vladimir poutine
très probablement n'est pas un stratège
c'est un tacticien c'est à dire qu'il
réagit au coup par coup
simplement ça veut dire que poutine est
un homme aussi d'affect d'émotion triste
et sombre mais d'émotions et c'est là
qu'il est imprévisible parce que pour
lui ce qu'il défend
ce n'est pas
le régime communiste sous l'urss dont il
parlait il disait que c'était un cap une
catastrophe non c'est l'ordre la
dimension verticale de l'ordre avec ce
qu'ils ne soient qu ils ne doivent pas à
protester et les vassaux eux doivent
être absolument aligner les autres ceux
qui protestent ce sont des ennemis c'est
ça la conception de poutine après
comment elle se marie avec les
circonstances je ne sais pas mais sa
conception sa colonne vertébrale c'est
celle que je viens de décrire merci
beaucoup gauthier à remercier pour votre
décryptage unionpay